radi pas mais les rendements sur les
appels
mauvaise encore r les pop et temporelle
continue nos héros sont toujours à la
recherche du docteur simon le père
d'iris nous les avions laissés dans un
bateau qu'on veut au large de l'île de
la réunion en l'an mille sept cent
disent prêts à se faire découper par la
buse le célèbre pirate sanguinaire
après tout il a une hache il faut bien
qu'ils s'en servent à voir les gens
c'est pas compliqué soit ils me donnent
de l'argent pour que je tue quelqu'un
soit juteuse liminaire comme conception
david j'aime beaucoup on est plutôt dans
la première catégorie le suc et voler ou
cherchent à sûreté du tas ya
scientifiques y arriver ya pas longtemps
vous voulez tuer non ose aller écouter
un match elle a le goût de la mort si
vous tuez vous vous entendez six matches
mais nuit alors ça c'est le trouvez
votre adresse email
tout à l'heure si tu es là il fait
tourner en bourrique le prix augmente
sinon ce bateau est dans ce qu'on peut
être négociée plus tard ça c'est vous
qui avez mis le feu à l'autre bateau
ouais pourquoi donc parce que je suis un
bien
jacky tout le monde si jamais le fun que
vous pourriez pas comme le bateau et ne
remonte pas à quoi bon bein moi si je
veux pas brûler des bateaux a tranché
la turbie émission très spéciale pour
moi
une mission que seul grand pirate grand
fou je suis le plus grand des pirates
vous menez as été un peu flou mais ils
méritent elles tuer tout vous voulez se
torturent vous le dirai quand l'un
d'entre nous dira lé de signal il se
signale ce sera le mot m
preuve voilà pas facile hein vous ne
tuez pas à tant que jeunes d'entre nous
n'a pas dit quand vous voudrez
j'entends à des lieues à la ronde j'vais
pas le look c'est mon mot de passe à
perdre 1 c'est pas super c'est qu'une
personne de pirater une machine à café
direction la caserne je ne sais pas
pourquoi mais j'ai l'impression tout ça
est un très mauvais plan le scientifique
a passé à travers tous les jours en
début de soirée on pourra pas l'arabe
est double faire du monde durable pour
ces gars là est pour moi hors de l'eau
bois jasmin au moyen-age de l'eau à
l'écran latrines leur tient depuis deux
jours j'aime pas la quinqua sur mon
bateau est couchée par mois
j'imagine
et voilà les trois mois mais un verre
d'eau pour la 3g une foule que les
aventures qu'on vit ensemble même frôlé
la mort et c'est dans ces moments là
qu'on réalise que l'amour c'est lui
qu'on aimerait janvier ce n'est vous des
étoiles
quoique je peux être immédiatement
maintenant on a une mission je veux
rencontrer son père inquiet follement un
grand homme non non je t'arrête tout de
suite mon père me par an consomme
c'est un homme qui a jamais lever le nez
de ses inventions pour regarder un
dessin je vais fait quand j'étais ado je
suis parti une semaine sans prévenir
concurrents prime à jeudi tapha tine
baun maurice
il a quand même inventé la machine à
voyager gentil vivre le moment présent à
barcelone tout ça un peu lâche on essaye
d'en voir je moi si tu me faisais un
dessin j'accroche pas au frigo en
consistance en plus de sa sensibilité la
marque
ça doit être mon père à l'auditoire de
gravitation
lorsque ces tombes en vérité il est
attiré par la tête et notifications
c'est le scientifique
[Applaudissements]
à vrai dire vous m'avez projeté au sol
vous avez exercé nos forces en plus de
celles de la gravité
il faudrait plutôt mais soulever et vous
me lâcher intéressant non n'exercer
aucune force de propulsion et pourtant
j'ai skié droit vers le sol
c'est la terre qui maintient bien essayé
dans l'eau pour moi si la durée dans
l'eau traverse une aide au long des
opérations et forcément rapport des
gouvernants il faut l'éviter mais c'est
newton unis fribourg courir à l'égard
rom gratuit pour le premier au bar
mon rêve c'est bon nous sommes à l'abri
dans cette source
merci mais roy faut qu'on se dépêche
avant que l'adulte reviennent parce que
à votre avis qui t'es quoi aux gens qui
s'en suit pendant qu'il est aux
toilettes
au fait il était super super nes que
newton qu'est ce que vous faites là vous
visite en angleterre pays
mais je suis venu ici pour réfléchir une
nouvelle théorie et prendre un peu de
vacances
ce sont clairement les pires vacances de
ma vie je suis un grand scientifique
très respecté dans mon pays savez vous
comment j'ai découvert la théorie de la
gravitation universelle marché sous un
arbre quand soudain une des dépassements
la buse n'est pas loin une poire mais
nouvelles sur la tête attendait une voie
dans les niveaux nous a toujours dit
j'ai toujours été passionné par les
sciences
depuis je suis au comme 3par chatons
qu'on aurait mis les uns sur les autres
je suis très mignon mais tianyuan auriez
vous rencontrez un entretien antifit
tout à fait voyez vous un certain
docteur simon m'a approché pour en
savoir plus sur le métier aurait
abandonné sur l'infiniment moyens et
s'il y avait quelque chose entre
l'infiniment grand et l'infiniment petit
ce n'est ni grand ni fini ni infini ni
passé ni présent ni nous n'est dû ni
froid ni chaud oui bon là c'est en
incomprise tu m'étonnes qu'il
abandonnait cette théorie mais pourquoi
mon père s'est intéressé à ça je suis
plaisir de parler avec quelqu'un qui me
comprenait et ensuite il m'a volé mon
carnet il dispose il a dit quelque chose
avant de partir genre allez salut je
devais aller à fait mort ok cool il a
précisé qu'il partait chez guy maillard
pour y déposer une relique les mayas une
relique
oui une relique qui contient une
collision
autre isaac newton john soutien du
départ la hache et la buse et la belle
isabelle roumanie signal guigui vous
avez dit que le tuer parce qu'aucun
d'entre nous disait pas comme je dis
comme c'est logique on ne peut pas lui
reprocher ça c'est quoi cette histoire
mon père a déposé une relique chez les
mayas
j'ai la trace d'un passage d'une
insertion dans la civilisation maya
en quinze 124 maintenant donnez moi mais
8000 piette
vous savez je fais un super sympa mais
bien sûr on revoit vous peinez attendait
ne bougez pas je les cherche je cherche
encore
nous voici dans le sud du mexique
en quinze 124 la température extérieure
est très précisément de 29 degrés
centigrades la faune sauvage se
composait de la marne données vous aussi
ça vous fait un truc bizarre ou les
intestins oui j'entends non ça c'est une
longue que t'as bu dans la taverne et tu
penses à dire qu'on va payer pour cent
qu'est ce qui s'est passé la bnb nuit et
là il fait jour où qu'on aille
par quelle magie sont de nouvelles
terres sa seule présence a plané
préparer mes débuts je vais prier vient
de lâcher un pirate sanguinaire civils
maliens mais où peut bien être le
docteur simon que va-t-il arriver à nos
héros et dans les îles de cette drôle de
reliques tout ça je le sais vous
aimeriez bien être à ma place
rendez vous au prochain épisode de
l'épopée temporaire
merci d'avoir écouté le cinquième
épisode de l'épopée temporel n'hésite
pas à ta bonnet et à mettre un pouce en
l'air et on se retrouve dans deux
semaines et oui c'est les vacances